When we look at an apple like this we
don't necessarily think of beauty, we
think of what's happening to the apple,
but I'm a mycologist by training so what
I look at this, when I look at this I
think, gee, look at all that spore
production there, look at all that's
going on with that apple.
Rotten apples seems like an odd thing to
come out and look at, but these are a set
of models that were part of a series
that the Blaschkas did. They illustrate
the diseases of plants, they are blown
glass, and they're painted and they're
colored, they're fantastic
representations of what the real things
look like.
For me it's looking at these and
realizing that if I zoom in I bring out
my microscope and I look at these, there's
fantastic structures to be seen; we have
one model that is particularly
instructive in that way it's called
Aspergillus; it's a glass model of a
fungus and if you kind of let yourself
think about this it's almost like
walking through a forest, it's so
beautiful the way in which it's arranged
and it shows these developmental stages
of how the spores are formed.
These models are part of a kind of
experimental series with Rudolf
Blaschka where he was using different
techniques and different classes; in some
cases the the glass had a kind of
effervescence on the surface of the
apple and so each of these was cleaned
to remove that powdery coating and then
they were painted and touched up so that
they are really kind of the apple of our
eye, we can look at them and appreciate
them as objects that are both the model
and they remind us of apple pie, of candy
apples, and all those wonderful things.
We think of the museum as being a
primary way in which Harvard research
and activities can be presented to the
public and in an exhibit like this, which
we think is topical and important for
people to realize about food security
and food sources, it's another way to
reach out and reach the public and
because of its beauty, because of the
rarity of these models, and because of
the stories that we can tell around the
apples and their diseases, we think that
the public will leave with a broader
appreciation of both museums and biology
of plants.